hallo mein name ist willkommen meine
lieben freunde wir spielen heute
gemeinsam ein spiel bei dem man einen
kleinen ninja über einen parcours leiten
muss und das ganze nur mit der eigenen
stimme wenn ich leise rede läuft der
normal und wenn ich laut rede dann
springt er alles klar ich würde sagen
ich zeig euch mal wie das ganze
funktioniert
so haben wir zwei münzen level tube fest
er will eins hab ich schon vor dem video
gespielt als kleine test runde weiter
[Musik]
die münze lauf kleines
ist es nach hinten gelaufen so dadurch
auf das mal so dann kann ich jetzt mal
noch ein bisschen langsam weiter laufen
[Musik]
ich kann es mittlerweile auf da er will
street level 4 meinl erstmal kurz
verschnaufen ich weiß ehrlich gesagt
nicht so richtig wie es weiter
die schwierige aus als es ist ich
schwöre dinge die sandra beim trinken
sagt falllinie uns abobo sanaa bei einer
lieben freundin hat heute geburtstag und
wir haben gestern geburtstag ein
gefeiert war waren wir liefern ähnlich
[Applaus]
geil offen zu ihrem geburtstag jetzt
haben auch revier umgekommen und neue
podcast folge es hat auch schon online
gegangen spotify dort uns lustig und so
ich will letzten level 8 kommen hier
[Musik]
so schlimm war ja erst mal kurz spieler
es war richtig gut
so setzen wir uns da erst mal hin zu
erwarten ist die das hab ich reden
a
in gruppe verdienst du dein geld a way
to
an magna vergeben
ein paar sekunden später aber meine
nachbarn geklopft das ist okay ist bei
mir
das ist doch nicht bar
[Applaus]
[Musik]
mir geht's gut leute mir geht es gut
jemanden ganz noch eine letzte chance so
haben wir hier kurz münze einen warten
weiß eben ist die spinne da gegangen ist
war das auch nicht gut so kleiner ninja
weiter geht's hier ist hier nach vorne
auf erkannte ich bin richtig gut da drin
dinge die ich während der schulzeit
leider nie sagen konnte 99 luftballons
[Applaus]
horizont sieht man für ufos aus dem raum
schlägt als mord liga staffel hinterher
anzugeben sowie
weil man dort
a
ohrid so nur 99 luftballons
ddp
[Musik]
an der stelle ich das heute wieder jetzt
allerdings auch wenn meine lieben
freunde sorry das ist heute mal ein
bisschen kürzer geworden ist allerdings
der spaß beiseite wie bereits gesagt hat
sander heute geburtstag gefeiert auch
gleich und deswegen wollte ich jetzt
nicht die ganze vom pc sitzen sondern
gleich zeit mit freunden verbringen
ich hoffe euch etwas wieder gefallen
wenn ich den zweiten teil von hochladen
soll dann lasten da macht unser video
hier da abonniert main kanal hier auf
den smiley mega entspannt verpasst ihr
sohn qualitativ hochwertigen content
nicht mehr dazu kommt jetzt ein anderes
video verlinkt habe ich gestern
hochgeladen hatte händel reactions und
wie bereits gesagt auch spotify neue
podcast folge online gegangen also hört
euch den mal auch annett die cops die
zocker aus san francisco